you know i'm glad you're here andy
because let's face it this is a very
strange time
it's such a very strange time and it's a
confusing time
because during covid we're being
bombarded with information
you know you turn on any tv you go on
your computer and they're going to show
you
graphs now some of these graphs are
important but here's what i'm noticing
a lot of the graphs that are coming out
lately don't seem that necessary have
you noticed that
absolutely yeah a lot of silly stuff
yeah
you know for example i mean some of
these charts are
i don't know they just seem questionable
here's a chart that came out today
there's apparently been a huge increase
in second naps
okay look at this there's been a 400
increase in day drinking i'm drunk now
i know i could tell yeah that's a good
reason to sit far away from me is the
smell
yeah yeah i was i got a little closer to
you earlier and i just smelled bathtub
gin
yep yep check this graph out there's
been a steady increase of watching
another goddamn show on netflix
i guess look at this one this is not a
surprising chart but i don't know that
we needed to see this one check it out
here's the national rate of masturbation
okay is that a chart we needed to see i
don't know
i i kind of getting off on it i'm kind
of getting off on it okay take it easy
yeah yeah
i think because you know the graph is
going
all right probably add a little bit of a
slide whistle sound
whoo yeah glad you're here
it's randy it can be i don't care
okay of course a sharp rise in dad's
shouting i used to be a very powerful
man
uh here's the latest graph on time
didn't really help me much to see that
they've also been tracking divorces by
spouses married to covet graph makers
little meta but uh wait that's a sad one
yeah
here's an interesting one what we talk
about with our walls
there's what's it like being a wall how
was your day
and wall you're my only friend i say
that a lot
here's a graph i actually found uh kind
of fascinating sharp increase of frat
brothers in alabama saying oh man
did you hear about trey
trey made a mistake portray and finally
given all the other data that's out
there
here's our last graph it's one uh
showing hope
always fun to end a comedy bit on a
happy note yeah
all right go out on a bummer yeah hey
andy do me a favor do it our audience
back in burbank would usually do oh all
right
it's my birthday
i want a hug
[Laughter]
do the string dance the t-shirt cannon
broke my teeth
yup we do miss our crowds though we do
they're some of the best people in
burbank